one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till two
[Music]
hey folks here we are get your drink on
we might be drunk with mark and sam
we're here
what's up yo i'm i'm chillin man what
are you doing
i just got back in town today uh from
raleigh and i'll tell you it's an hour
and eight minute flight i love it
and uh took a nap and i'm ready to have
a cocktail
oh what are you drinking well today i'm
going right in with maybe the best
scotch i own wow i want to see this
oh man you're going classy loggable in
16.
oh yeah i don't know where i got this
somebody gave it to me or
it was a gift but special occasion
class that's a classy man scotch
oh yeah or woman you know who's always
drinking that
on tour i'm sure you know oh yeah amy
schumer
yes maybe that's where i got it i have
no idea where this came from i wish i
did know but uh yeah this
uh i've been sitting on this one and you
know it's the 12th step that's a
milestone i guess you know 12 steps
12 f what uh
did you do this when you're on tour with
her because a lot of people
you know may not know this but the rider
you get the rider you get it in your
dressing room
you she'd have the booze in her dressing
room which i'm sure she didn't take
yes and then you get the booze in your
dressing room which i'm sure
you took so you took yours and hers i
took
mine home i took hers home and i took
all her food
i didn't want to be too uh too high
maintenance so i was just like give me
one bottle of this
and a couple of granola bars and some
beef jerky and i'm out
cause you know you don't want to buy a
beef jerky on your own that shit's like
8.99 that's such a
that's such a man rider i love it
granola beef and scotch yes
i want to be throw i want to just be
able to throw it in my bag and get
moving i got my
my starch my meat and my liquor when i
was out with her i think i got your
rider a lot of the time so i
uh when i was out with her i remember
there'd be like art bag which is
great winter scotch yeah pd very good
very good scotch
well you're this is the king of petey
lafroyag and lagavo and what you have
right now
that's true yeah just a dark bottle oh
my god i love it it's so
thick and smells like bacon man
yes much like my ex
but uh wait a minute is it what's more
what
what
is more overpriced beef jerky
or printer ink
i i haven't owned a printer in the years
oh yeah i mean
either do you even yeah it's like
whenever i talk to someone who's like 50
they're like you [ __ ] millennial
but i don't own a printer but i'm like
why do i need one like well i don't get
what i
i guess like if you're writing a script
and you want to look at it
on a page rather than on the screen but
like i don't need a
oh i'd really use it for is probably
contracts and then what am i going to
scan [ __ ] this sounds like a whole
i can just download an app i can write
my thing in like why do i need a printer
i know but there was like a five year
period where you kind of had to have one
everybody printed their boarding pass
you had to print it out and sign it
there was always some need for a printer
i would go to the i would go to the
store and print out my boarding pass and
then i would print the return ticket
in the hotel uh lobby that's right
in the little conference what do you
call that it was like the business suite
or whatever [ __ ] which we've all
jerked off in before let's be honest
the business center the business center
yeah yeah the center a little grandiose
i know i'm going down to the business
center it's one computer
next to a bunch of like chex mix from
the [ __ ]
yeah exactly oh i hated that computer it
was always so slow you had to log in you
didn't know your password it was a
nightmare
there was always some old guy on it
before you and you're like please just
let me print out my [ __ ] boarding
pass
he was looking at like sunsets you're
like what is yeah i don't know oh yeah
oh yeah that was that was remember the
you might not have had this as a
manhattan kid but growing up in the 90s
we had the computer room
and you had to have it it was like a you
had a designated room for the computer
for porn for ebay
for googling stuff directions
yeah we did and i remembered the aol
like log
like it made noise you had to be careful
like you were doing a heist just to jack
off back in the day
yeah yeah that was that was an exciting
sound back there
the towel under the door for weed for
the sound
towel played a big role in adolescence
yes and that
towel was crunchy let's be honest
oh man was that a that was a wild time
and remember jerking off with the
headphones in because i was like oh i'll
be stealthy but then you you're also
freaking out because you don't know if
footsteps are coming damn that's right
noise canceling
it's got its perks it's also got its
problems yes exactly exactly
just every i used to do this thing where
i'd watch a
playboy tv the scramble but you jerk off
with one hand and
the other hand was on the last channel
button on the remote control
that was a big one the lasso like
someone walks in you pull it up
and you switch exactly yeah boom i'm
back on pbs
your mom's even more suspicious that
you're watching pbs
she'd rather watch you [ __ ] it's like
the thing is like what's what's weird or
watching a 13 year old boy jacking off
or walking in you're like are you just
watching bob ross what the hell
yeah i'm watching julia child mom get
out of here
hello well i'm drinking uh an old pal
this is it's called an old towel that's
the name of the drink
it's a classic drink it's basically
a play on the boulevardier which is like
a
kind of like a boulevardier is a negroni
but with whiskey instead of gin so it's
campari
sweet vermouth bourbon right wow
the old pal is what i'm drinking is one
part campari
one part bourbon and one part dry
vermouth
not sweet dry wow nicely done
it's it's a good ass drink some people
go a little heavier on the whiskey
and a little lighter on the other two i
think it goes pretty well equal parts
but uh
it's a nice drink man it feels it looks
good i drank it at a show the other
night and i got everyone there it was
like what is that and the bartender
tried and goes
i'm having one of these everyone started
drinking an old pal an old pal
for an old pal we're doing a old pals
doing a podcast
yes here here that looks it looks kind
of almost fruity and
and punchy it's not it's kind of like
tart but i like i don't like a too sweet
cocktail except
manhattan is like the one sweet cocktail
i like
yes it's got a bite to it where it's
like a old pal
it's like almost like uh
i mean it's weird it's like kind of
campari with bourbon i don't think you
see it a ton so i kind of
kind of like that no great choice i love
it i love i've never heard of it
but it's a good looking drink it just
it's something sad about calling your
cocktail your friend
that's my old pal you know the wife left
me and this is the only
thing i can rely on old tried and true
here
the only thing worse than old pal is old
faithful
yes the only thing that i could count on
to help me through life
i didn't realize how i thought it was
like a joyous drink you just made me
realize how sad this drink is
i mean don't get me wrong i love a good
cocktail but yeah there is something sad
about calling you
your drink your buddy
[Laughter]
come here amigo exactly
what uh give me uh give me any toast
this week
oh geez uh i wanted
this is this is a weird one but it's not
a thing it's not a
person or an object but i've been trying
to get a little more
uh i don't know if classy's the right
word but
i bought a watch i got a watch let's see
it's a piece of [ __ ] it's a casio it's
30 but uh
i just love this thing i love doing that
move like
i love that and then i have another
thing where i'm trying to get a little
more james bondy
where i wear my jacket and i keep things
in the inside
pocket i love an inside pocket don't you
feel
pulling shades out of there or pulling a
pen or
or whatever it is your wallet so i'm i'm
toasting the inside
pocket wow that's a great toast i love
it i love
i love what you just said about the
inside pocket because
i never wear blazers when i have a
jacket within i can't wait till i wear a
blazer by the way i can't wait to go for
a blazer and it doesn't look ridiculous
on me yes
exactly i feel the same way i think the
seinfeld look is like great
jeans a blazer and like he's like the
only dude left wearing nike shocks
i've never seen anyone else he's wearing
like the like 90s nike i think
i don't know someone i think has a bit
about this how you like you wear
whatever year you peaked in forever it's
his bit
well it's like that's what he did it's
like you're wearing the 90s
outfit so true but yeah the
inside of the jacket pocket man you it's
fun to pull out
shades that's like the coolest pull out
i think coolest pull it just looks
so classy you look like a man like you
got your [ __ ] together
and uh it's tucked away i don't know
there's something about it
and i'm with you on the blazer i love a
sports coat
but i just can't do it i mean i'm a
child but we're like bomber age we're
like
you know bomber jacket maybe like i'll
have a i have a couple slick jackets but
i always feel
a little weird you know yeah same but
that trench coat you got that's pretty
badass
yeah i love a trench coat man i just if
i see it i'm like i'm not like a big
go to the place and shop but i where i
found that like century 21
brought down a shitload of money and
it's just like oh [ __ ] i feel i put it
on i was like i feel like a pi
i [ __ ] love this yes i love a trench
and i like an old gordon gekko like the
beige one with the belt yes
but i just i could never do i'd see you
could
you could i don't think i could do
that's so professional it's so
uh adult you know what the problem is
we still feel like kids yeah we feel we
feel because of our careers like i
just another thing jerry would always
say is that like
however many years you've done stand-up
is like how old you actually are
so we're teenagers right right right you
put up
you put a jacket like that on as a
teenager you were in our heads it's
almost like whenever i put an outfit on
i'm like what's
what what's colin quinn and keith
robinson of the comedy cellar gonna say
a hundred percent every time and then
you take that puppy right back off
because like i don't want to deal with
it but
that's why i respect women women just
wear what they want like my gal
she dresses very adult and sexy
and professional and it looks great
she's got these cool italian boots with
a
with a trench coat and like one of those
hats and i could never do it but girls
can do it girls can be
fashionable that's because women are
supportive
no woman takes a fashion risk and rolls
into a restaurant and has her friend
roll her eyes
they might do it internally like this
[ __ ] thinks she's hotter than me
she gets abused the bathroom they're
like that was a bit much
but they don't do it to her they do it
our guy friends do that to our face
like yes i can't roll in in like a
new outfit even if it's not bad even if
it's just new
they will make second guess it that's so
true
it's so true what is that in men that
why do we do
ah that doing everything even you get a
hair hey nice haircut there
[ __ ] or whatever it is you know it
you just can't help it
and i'm i'm guilty of it myself the only
thing worse than
nice haircut is got a haircut i know i
know yeah
you're just you're just telling me that
i got what i know i got
that's all it's almost like we're saying
i want you to be aware that i'm aware
that you're changing things
yeah you're not like like we think we're
getting one past them maybe my hair was
getting long maybe it was time
yes people get haircuts it's not weird
but yeah i mean
it's because you need to comment on it
though you're right they got it it's a
guy thing
and and jerry speaking of him he hates
the bomber he's like you kids with the
bombers like get a get a [ __ ]
sports coat get a jacket that ain't a
jacket that's like a
windbreaker and i'm like ah times have
changed the old geezer
i don't i think a bomber can look good
man but i hear him i think like
you know what he was probably so
successful when he was his our age that
he was like it made sense also no one
rocked that [ __ ] in the 80s you know
like no
he was rocking a suit like look at those
old gary shandling clips on
on carson he's in like armani you know
like they they were just more adult than
us
we have gotten younger and and we're
dressing younger too like
our behavior is younger yes yes i mean
think about it
i was just talking to my friend about
this my dad i saw a photo of him when he
was 31 and he's in a full business suit
black business suit in the
louisiana heat with a briefcase and i'm
like
wow 30. i'm 37. now i'm
wearing a hoodie right now i'm wearing
pajama pants and
uh it's a pair of pants it's weird yeah
i was watching okay so i was watching
the odd couple last night old
old movie you know walter matthau jack
lemmon
sure and they have like a date and the
women are just coming over to their
apartment
and they're in suits they're not like he
doesn't have to wear a suit
he just put on the tie they're like
getting ready in a time like it's kind
of adorable
can you imagine if you if like we had a
double date come over and i was like
you know you're cooking in the other
room i'm like putting a tie on i'm like
hurry up
hurry up with a meatloaf mark so true
that's insane but it is adorable it's
like sunday's best or it
yeah there's something uh innocent about
it but yeah it's just i don't know when
that faded away maybe in the 90s but uh
it just doesn't fly anymore well they're
still trying to get laid they just
had a nicer exterior right
they were still being dudes they're
still like don't blow this i'm trying
to bang these british broads but but
he's wearing he's got a little tie on
it's cuter
it's cute but it was almost a
respectable thing like just have some
respect for yourself like
we're going into a dangerous zone with
sweatpants now sweatpants
look too fashionable i see guys in
sweatpants
everywhere and i'm like if you would
have walked around in sweatpants in the
80s
you'd be considered homeless or
unemployed
or or you know a pervert yes and now
they look
so normal it's too risky
it's not healthy you know what it is
it's
it became uncool to try
like here's the thing like i think of
someone like george carlin who like we
consider to be one of the great writers
of all time one of the great performers
of all time
imagine george carlin going into like a
brooklyn room right right now
with like rehearsed material right right
carlin's bit would they would hit harder
if after he'd be like or whatever
and he's like reading them off a sheet
of paper they don't hit when he's like
they're just like look at this guy
trying yeah
good point good we've kind of adapted
that or adopted that all over society
and i mean look at an airplane back in
the day you put a tuxedo
on basically to get on an airplane and
now everybody on airplanes got
flip-flops on and
a chihuahua that's such a good point and
it's because we are
we're just jaded we're not grateful
flying is incredible
think about it flying is an incredible
thing but we're not
we're not we're just like i'm [ __ ]
i'm wearing sweatpants it's and look
security's gotten heightened in our
defense like
you gotta i'm not gonna put on like like
what are you gonna wear like dress shoes
to go through security i'm wearing like
fly knits i'm wearing whatever i can
slip off easiest you know what i mean
but good point good point
but you you're right there was something
about an airplane was like man that must
have been like hot that must have been
like a hot way to like pick up a woman
back in the day
she's in like you know a blouse right
right you're you're in a blazer you're
both on business
yeah well i think a ticket back then was
expensive
and you appreciated it and now i mean
flight there's 18 airlines his spirit
this frontier we've really scraped the
barrel here and the ticket's 18
so it's almost like it's become more
gray houndy just in the sky
that's a good point yeah you're not it's
not like it's not that cool to fly
anymore
right but i miss like i love i used to i
mean look i'm gonna get back at it soon
but like i
i liked my routine of flying where i can
just like
you know zone out from the world like
there are very few places you can
disconnect from the world
yes we're down to airplanes and showers
that's so true yeah you're right great
point yeah it's uh
it's not much and i used to be like oh
my phone doesn't work but now it's kind
of a blessing
yeah it's i mean i definitely panic when
my phone doesn't work i'm not gonna lie
like
we've gotten way it's funny when you
watch like a revenge movie you watch
like john wick and you're like oh that's
how i behave when wi-fi goes out for 20
minutes
you know it's like it's embarrassing but
it's good for us man oh yeah i mean just
think of all the thoughts you had
i don't know when you were 18 that were
just swirling through your brain that
you might not have now because you're on
tick tock looking at some you know
dad doing a dance in his kitchen it's so
true and and
man scorsese had a great point in an
interview recently where he said like
movies aren't about an algorithm you
know what i mean like algorithms are bad
because it doesn't put good
[ __ ] to the top it puts what's getting
uh
engagement to the top and engagement
isn't necessarily good
yeah whereas this dude you know he puts
so much work into what he does
and like [ __ ] if it was like if this if
whatever equivalent he was and
another you know say he was trying to
break on social media
no one's going to see his [ __ ] right
they're going to see like the
transformers equivalent right
so yes great great point i mean
you can do that with mcdonald's
mcdonald's is eight million served it's
got
six million people coming out of there
every day but it's still [ __ ]
it's mcdonald's i know this i like
mcdonald's but
i like i like it as [ __ ] yeah well yeah
yeah of course
of course but if we're putting top-notch
restaurants
you're right mcdonald's is going to be
the the tick-tock
above it it's going to be algorithmed
above it just because it's
hit more so yeah that's not a good
measure of quality
it's just a good measure of quantity
yeah
yeah i don't know man it's uh
it's it's yeah algorithm just the word
upsets me for some reason i'm just like
i i don't like that i that i
know the word i don't like that i that
we have to know this much
you're so right like people used to just
be able to open their minds and just go
for what like
i have to be like this clip get this
clip done get this clip done
caption like you can't just disengage
like you used to
and still have a career i know it's
horrible
and some people have done it some people
have done it but
uh i don't i think at our level we're
not there yet
but who like name someone well like i
don't think john mulaney
who's a great comic i don't think he's
sitting around cutting up clips but he's
at that level where people are cutting
up clips
that they like of him and putting them
on if he if he
popped when we like he popped like
seven years ago or something it's
different like if he popped now
i think it would be different really i i
do
yeah i think it's maybe not with like
netflix who knows but
yeah i think i mean melanie's a beast so
i think no matter what
that dude is just inevitable you know
yeah yeah
well that was another thing you heard a
lot the cream rises the cream rises and
you're like yeah i know the cream rises
but i also gotta you gotta know that
i've got cream
you know what i mean like just because
it's good doesn't mean you know about it
yeah no it's it's not and it's another
thing when like when people
i think another thing people want to
discover [ __ ] on their own like how
often do you recommend a show to someone
and they're like yeah yeah i'll watch it
yeah but they don't but they don't watch
it they want to discover the show
so true so true it's kind of like uh
when you got that [ __ ] boss you got to
let the boss think he came up with it
and then he's on board with your idea
you got to make sure he thought of it
in a weird way it's kind of human nature
but yeah it's
it's how people are wired yeah
yeah it's like a a blind date like if
i'm like you gotta go out with this
chick you're gonna love her oh my god
you're like all right easy what's her
problem why are you pushing her so hard
but if you had bumped into her at
you know the the starbucks you might be
into her
yeah availability is unattractive yeah
yeah oh you got that i mean it's
speaking you know speaker woody allen i
mean like
you know the groucho marx show we've
talked about forever but like the
why do we you know i don't want to be a
member of a club that's going to have me
that's it's so true but in every part of
your life
i think about that [ __ ] all the time and
it's yeah by the way speaking of blind
dates
that was gonna be one of my
recommendations uh for this week
rewatching old clips of the show blind
date on youtube i used to love that show
dude it's such a good show yeah the
writers are [ __ ] witty
like whatever the captions they're
putting it's a train wreck if you
haven't seen it's like from the late 90s
and it looks it
like it looks late 90s yep yeah horrible
graphics like weird pop-up animation uh
man and it was fun though i mean it was
a slice of life
it's so good dude and it's usually a
train wreck of a date like
they get way too i'm watching them drink
and i'm like they just have seven drinks
on the first date yeah
yeah yeah that's like that is like
almost like a
like that they're like this is america
this is what people do in america they
get this [ __ ] up on a first date
oh yeah oh yeah and you can see every
time like you get five minutes in you're
like they seem normal and then 12
minutes in you're like
she's got issues he's a piece of [ __ ]
you can you start seeing oh this is why
you're single
and on a reality show you [ __ ] losers
but it's so
it's so [ __ ] on the nose where like
you're right well you're like these
people are fine they're normal and then
they get a few drinks in them
like on one of them this woman went out
with this ufc fighter he's like she's
like i like bad boys okay we got set up
with a bad boy he's a [ __ ]
professional fighter he's a badass he's
like six eight he's
big and she's like mad that he doesn't
drink that's the whole thing she's like
she's like you don't drink
so he gets [ __ ] drunk on the date
with her she's like he's like i'll drink
and then she's like but yeah but you
don't
drink and it's like well what do you
want you
seems like he's doing everything it
seems like you want
it's weird when someone's an alcoholic
and they're like you're not an alcoholic
too it's like
well guess what doesn't work two
alcoholics ah yes
you need a sober guy who will hold your
hair back while you're vomiting that's
what you need
yeah it's so true and he's ufc he can
carry
home he can get you in a headlock i mean
it's the perfect
perfect uh match-up you know what is
even better or not
i think blind date's better but have you
ever remember eliminate
oh yeah there was a limited blind date
fifth wheel
and next next was trash i think that was
mtv
mtv's trash horrible horrible talk about
algorithm
dog [ __ ] yes but uh dude eliminate was
like the
the four women or four dudes and the one
yeah and they're trying to
so it's like the by the four by the last
round it was always like
it was always like what are you gonna do
yeah yeah
what are you gonna do to earn this spot
and it was like one of them would take
their shirt off the other one be making
out with them you're like this would not
fly
now and i [ __ ] love it it's so fun
and that was normal tv that was on basic
cable or prime time and
i think singled out might have been the
uh
the what is it the gateway drug or what
do you call it the epicenter the
beginning
what do you call that when the first one
that starts it all
the the the uh groundbreaker i don't
know yeah
you're looking you're looking for a
negative term ah
that's just a terror it was the
precedent precipice
i don't know what about so were you
jenny mccarthy or carmen elektra
i well i watched both because i was into
both of them but i think carmen
electra's
got a better face yeah but i hate
jenny mccarthy i don't i don't like when
we call her funny i'm like no
she's wacky she's loud and goofy but
she's not funny she's got nothing
she's got no zingers you would have to
if you dated her you'd have to
pull she'd be on like you know oh
god i know it'd be a nightmare yeah like
look you're beautiful you got a hell of
a bod but
uh i haven't heard one clever quip
you're just farting it's a lot of it was
a lot of like i'm hot and i farted it
was a lot like
it was a lot of like i made a weird face
and you're like
[ __ ] jim carrey holy [ __ ] this is
incredible
yeah yeah and uh by the way chris
hardwick what a dream gig you get to
stand there read a couple cue cards and
talk [ __ ] and and get away with it he's
smarmy he's sarcastic he was just being
a [ __ ]
to everybody and it was great yeah that
was a good mtv had a minute man it's so
funny how it
mtv just like collapsed it's like
yeah viacom viacom was just like we're
not going to adapt
so mtv like i mean it's crazy to think
how big
mtv was you they could break it they
could make your career like we got it on
mtv
you're in it's but it's all
it's all just the internet now it's so
funny how it's like mtv
what was the last big thing catfish or
like jersey shore
catfish those were both huge i think
but it's [ __ ] it's kind of done yeah
mtv's over but uh
you know what was crazy about uh what's
it called uh singled out was
that you know they'd be like blonder
brunette and they gotta go blonde
so they'd be all right all you
brunette's gotta get out of here and
then one of them when the lady was in
the chair would go
big dick or little dick and she'd go get
rid of those little dicks and a bunch of
dudes just walked away you're like wow
you're on tv just saying i got a little
dick and i'm getting kicked out
i was like remember that with a tiny
dick going oh my god this is so
embarrassing
this is your tv moment
that's a nightmare that's [ __ ] that's
hilarious
women will [ __ ] do [ __ ] with like no
body shaming
and then [ __ ] dad around the corner
body shaming is disgusting
big is beautiful and you're like all
right well apparently only on on your
side
you know what i mean like totally i mean
chris christie jokes are still flying
it's it's [ __ ] is a hilarious about
and they'll say you know women are more
judged for their body which look
they are it's true it's completely true
but it is hilarious where you're like
chris christie is like
really [ __ ] fat you're like you're
making fun of a dude who
i don't know how he survived covet like
that's a that's like a
tough that we were like you got cope and
you're like i'm sorry dude this this
might be it
yeah you're a goner that's so true with
the and look women are judged
by their looks and all that but let's
not act like it's only
men judging men do judgment but so do
women i mean i'm at a party with my lady
and this beautiful girl walks in and i'm
like who's that my girl's like i don't
know but i hate her
like you never met her and then if a
dumpy chick walks in she's like
something about her i like
like you don't know her either but you
but don't you when if a dude walked into
a party and he's like jacked and a tank
top
isn't a party that's like develop a
[ __ ] personality
completely completely yeah so i told her
i do get when women are like
she's a skank i'm kind of like yeah i
get it i definitely like it
if a dude rolls in like that i'm just
kind of like
nothing cooler to me than finding out a
guy is low-key ripped
oh yeah that is a good move like like
our buddy
doug key like ripped like but he doesn't
show it off at all
he's like a dude that like you only find
out he's ripped because
you like you know went to a swimming
pool with him and you're like oh [ __ ]
that guy's jet
yeah yeah he could have posted eight
million photos and he never did
yeah that's cool there's something i
mean like look i mean but also if you're
a comic don't
that's the thing is like don't you don't
you want to lead with your personality
of course of course you'd think i mean
for most of us that's all you got
yeah i got let me see what i got for can
i give you a pet peeve
oh please my favorite part of the show
this has become my favorite part of the
show too
the pet peeves so here's one that's for
me is
and i don't mean to be insensitive if
you're an addict i think it's great that
you're working on [ __ ]
i really do but here comes the butt
the addict making amends and how it's
still
all about you okay so
i got a call he's a friend of mine i i
still like the guy
i really do but i got a call and he
texts me first he goes i need to call
you this week you know uh
i was i was a really bad drunk and i'm
sober now and i'd like to
talk to you about it i said i don't
think you were that bad honestly i
really i didn't like i'm thinking about
him at his worst and i'm like
a lot of laughing a lot of high-fiving a
lot of good times
and he goes i was a really really bad
drunk and i said again
i don't think you were i said i think
you were pretty good drunk and he goes
just trust me i was bad so he calls me i
said all right let's talk
and he's like all that [ __ ] i said about
you you know
starting out as a comic when i was like
ah he doesn't have it all that and i'm
like
well this is all news to me
wow so it's one of the things i'm like
okay well i'm glad you cleared your
conscience
you ruined my day yeah right jesus
now i need another one later about this
exactly the addict mentality it's like
it's very good that you're getting sober
but like
let's also like people that are
supportive of you let's [ __ ] be nice
to them too i'm supporting you dude
yeah yeah wow that is wild i
i i know this is i think no no no you
don't oh yeah okay
not a not a comic ah wow
and i will say this he is a good guy he
meant well
but i told him hey i don't want to hear
it i like you i accept you that's kind
of what i said to him i i
i'm good with it and i for the record he
said like i took advantage
i don't think i don't feel that you took
advantage of me i would tell you like i
i'm pretty
honest about that i got i gotta give
kudos to you
because i think a lot of people would
get that kind of [ __ ] and run with it
and milk it
and like oh yeah keep it coming baby but
you're like no no you're fine
and you could have made that a whole
bigger thing and made it about you but
you
you you pushed on i think that's that's
noble well it's not about me it's his
[ __ ]
problem is the thing so i mean when
someone gets sober i give you a lot of
credit because that's not easy and
that's
oh that's a whole thing like you've
changed your life around you know and
hey there's a drinking show but there's
a show we respect sober people too but
because that ain't easy can't do it
myself can't no i don't think i could
ever do it and i like alcohol too much
that i i don't think i could ever
become a full-on alcoholic because i
enjoy drinking too much
exactly you don't want to abuse it
because you don't want to lose it
i just love it i loved it it's funny
ever just having like a bad day and you
have a couple drinks and you're like
this is the perfect short-term solution
yes like i feel good again
right you just take the edge off that's
it i don't need to get
hammered i just want to like i just want
to relax
we talk about like beer goggles how you
like see a woman is hot but you ever get
like friend goggles
oh dude that's what a drinking buddy is
you know you got your guy
you can barely stand the guy and then
you have a couple cocktails you're like
oh buddy get in here you give me noogie
i love you man
and then you're like this next day sober
trying to think of one positive
characteristic and you're like yeah
you can't do it you can't do it that
that's a bit friend goggles that's great
maybe that's a bit what uh give me a
peeve i i would go as far i think some
people have relationship goggles i knew
guys in
high school who would just get
shit-faced with their girlfriend and
after that the booze wore off they'd
just start fighting again
that's tough yeah but that's a lot of
young couples too it's like you see like
uh [ __ ] man it's so often though those
young people that's why so many hot
divorce chicks in their 30s and 40s
where you're like all right well good
i'm glad he [ __ ] up
because now these like dating apps are
gonna be fun again you know
right you're right yeah and these women
are fresh in the rebound
they've got a low bar because they're
with a [ __ ] douchebag
all you have to do is show up and be
decent and they're like oh my god who
are you
oh nothing better than a woman who's
been treated horribly
for us
that was a good save comparison-wise
yeah
all right i got two one little one and
one big one
yeah i'll go a little and and stop me if
i brought this up before because it
just kills me every single time and i
had it today
i'm on the flight you know it's an early
fight it's like 10 a.m or whatever the
hell it is
i got the guy next to me window shade
open
sun beaming beaming and he's sleeping
in the wind in the sunshine and i'm like
yeah i got sunglasses on
i got the the safety lecture laminated
thing
up the glasses to like try to block it
close the [ __ ] show do you sleep at
home with a desk lamp in your eye
like it's insane it's so much light
it's unacceptable i think that's it's a
morning
on a morning flight that's a [ __ ]
dick move
it's weird and undeniable undeniable
dick move
it's undeniable but i don't think he was
trying to be a dick because i
i'm such a cun i sat down before the guy
next to me i was in the aisle and i went
whoop and i
reached over and lowered it because i
was like it's 10 in the morning sun's
coming in
and then he came in i got up he got in
his window scene he was like oh and he
looked out
he's allowed to look out the window he's
got the window seat but once you start
snoozing
close it baby oh that's it's careless
it's just not a
thoughtful move and i try to be a good
passenger to people i think it's
important like
like you know we're all in this together
on a flight like
you got to be good to your neighbor like
so
that drives me [ __ ] nuts man i i i'm
also a big sleeper on morning flights or
not even a sleeper but like a rester yes
completely do you bring a sleeping mask
for the flights or no
i used to but i i had it either in
packed in the bag the bags tucked away
in the overhead or i forgot it but i was
just
i was just like ah so here's what i did
he starts conking out
and i just reached right over and uh put
that puppy down
and do you say anything he woke up and
was like later i was like what the hell
i was like it must have fallen you know
these old planes
you never know that is but you know what
you're
that's i think fair i think if you just
if you even explain to him like hey
i was you were asleep i was trying to
sleep i didn't want to invade your space
you're in the [ __ ] right dude you're
probably yeah if i you're probably right
if i had said that it probably wouldn't
have been that big of a deal but some
people get weird but hey this is my
space you you don't want the window [ __ ]
then you should have sat by the window
and been in control whatever it is but
yeah
i'm with you some people fight for that
arm rest too when you're like hey man
i'm too old to fight you but let's
[ __ ] be reasonable here i
don't like i i also don't like when
you're with someone who's like huge
in the seat next to you so they just
think they're entitled right
hey man i'm six three i can't like you
don't get to just squash me i'm not a
[ __ ]
i'm not a [ __ ] dwarf here i need some
space
sometimes they come into your area and i
just try to like put a
i try to put something there to make a
divider
oh nice well
here's my thing about weight and this is
where we'll uh
we'll piss off the the the chunkies out
there but
i look at i look at fat people almost
like smokers like yeah you're you're
allowed to do whatever you want but now
you're
you're fat or you're i'm getting
second-hand fat now
yeah you know because you're bringing
that fat into my world so just because
you're huge
now i gotta suffer most of them are
pretty cool though i do think it's an
occasional thing
but i agree yes like let me if you're
gonna come into my area i get to use you
as a pillow that's what i said
if we're dipping into each other's world
i'm i'm [ __ ] leaning on you
i've had the the muscle bound dude the
muscle my dude's worse than the fat dude
that's worse
the muscle-bound dude is not even soft
right he's a rock it's like trying to
sleep on a [ __ ] brick
i'll take the pillow over the brick give
me the pillow any day louis cats used to
have this great joke he's like i love
fat chicks i love fat chicks
it's all their whole body is just tits
i used to love that joke uh but yeah
i'm with you uh if if the guy's fat and
he's allowing me to use it i'm guessing
that bits it better with dudes in the
crowd than women
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah nobody's complimenting
him
oh no louie is [ __ ] funny man i
remember we uh
remember that show at cbs when lu i i
told this story
so you and me were young comics and cbs
in the back
and you know we're just like young guys
drinking in the back
whispering like you know shooting the
[ __ ] gossipy and i remember
wayne rayda you know running the club in
the back would he would just turn to us
and go
during the show shut up shut the [ __ ] up
and we were just like ah and then yeah
yeah i'm so sorry shots
shots for everybody and it was like this
abusive yes he was kind of bipolary and
he would snap and then apologize
and then he'd like a weird time he'd
drag us in and like put
his arm around both of us and we'd all
shoot shots we're just like kids we're
like what are we doing
i know i know oh yeah we were just 24
25 just there for the alcohol and yeah
the place was the size of a post-it
stamp
and uh i bombed every time i was there
but what else what are we doing
remember when you [ __ ] another great
one is when you were dealing with some
heckler he's tackling every comic on the
show and this guy wouldn't stop tackling
you and you like put him down
enough ways but it got to a point where
you're like all right dude like what do
you want
and louis gomez gets in his [ __ ] face
and was like
you got a [ __ ] problem dude yeah and
the guy
the guy just like looks up like one and
goes you and me outside i was like
is this [ __ ] happening i watched
lewis like drag this dude outside in
front of his girlfriend and just yell
[ __ ]
and the guy and the guy's like ah and he
just keeps yelling
[ __ ] fight me in front of his date and
i'm just like i am so glad this guy is
on our side
right right i know jesus he's not even
angry he just wants to fight somebody
he also was like he had that thing where
he's like you [ __ ] with my boy
like you don't [ __ ] with my boy so i was
like dude i [ __ ]
i'm grateful to louis that's hilarious
yeah much respect
i still think about that i appreciate
that now here's a cbs
debacle i got into and let me hear your
your angle because i
i got yelled at for this but i didn't
think i was wrong okay
it's kind of a curvy enthusiasm moment
so every night at cbs you performed you
got a free meal that was like a big perk
of the gig
that was i mean wayne who would underpay
us would be like he would like pocket
the money that he was getting yeah he
would take from us and then he would be
like
but you need to try the chicken meal in
a so there's a champagne vinaigrette
it's one of the best
and we're eating dollar slices we're
eating uh mcdonald's so we're like
oh my god a rib eye or whatever it was i
spent i took a girl
uh uh there on new year's because it was
a free meal
[Laughter]
i accepted i no we got he fed her on new
year's
that's nice but it was like that was a
big deal i'm like free meal
yeah all right so i had
i would something happen where i went to
some show and i got a bunch of free food
so then i go to cb's into a spot they're
like you want a meal i was like no i'm
okay i'll get it later
and then go oh yeah well just let us
know when you want the meal so i do a
spot it's fun
i leave two nights later i come down and
i go hey let me get that uh
chicken paprikash and they were like oh
you're not on tonight i was like i know
i was on two nights ago but i never got
my meal
and they were like whoa whoa whoa you
only perform you only get a meal when
you perform
and i was like i did perform and i never
got the meal and now i'd like the meal
and they were like no that's crazy and
i'm like i performed
the transaction is still the same
there's just a little bit of time in
between
well here's here's the argument for both
sides the argument for your side is
if you perform that night and you didn't
collect your money
you still get to come back and get your
money oh
but maybe the meal is only on the table
for that one night
yeah it's almost like you know
it's like the argument like some of
these clubs let us drink for free
right do you drink for free on nights
you're not performing that's the
question
right right some clubs will say yes if
you work there enough
others won't so that's right i think the
food beverage thing is different from
the money but if we're talking
just purely money you are in the right
okay interesting see drinks is a little
gray because it's multiple drinks
it's a vague amount of drink but a meal
is a meal one
meal i don't know so we got into it i
never got the meal
yeah i mean i i would if it was my place
i'd be like yeah have the meal but i
always
i also get i get where they're coming
here's their argument
yeah so some comic had to leave what are
we feeding like 10 comics who didn't
have the meal now
[Laughter]
yeah yeah i guess i'm just a literal guy
i see
performing you get a meal if i come back
in 19
years i still expect a meal but
19 years is a bit steep it's probably a
different restaurant
that's true it's true the city shut down
yeah i think it is a gray area i don't
think there's i don't think you're right
but i don't think you're wrong i think
like i hear you and i think you have a
valid point but i get with
i do get where they're coming from when
they're like all right well you didn't
take the meal what are we like
we owe you for life now is there is
there
how long does this free meal really last
in your mind that's the ques i should
have gotten in writing
just a bar napkin hey wayne you owe me
one meal you got it
you know like a dumb and dumber 350
thousand hold on to that one
what about that was hilarious how the
hell he pocketed money
because he was the most charming guy i
really did enjoy him that was the funny
thing is
he knew how to [ __ ] compliment you he
knew how to make you feel good
yeah and we were so bankrupt of
compliments or any success or anything
so
any little compliment or nicety went a
long way back then
well like this guy managed patrice
o'neill yeah yeah
yeah he knows talent he managed patrice
you know
and he had great tit it was like all the
big guys there were guys it was like
vecchione and big j
and soder and nate pergatzi and i was
like man this guy knows comedy
yeah and i mean uh greer barnes would
work there it was all
funny people he had he did have good
adrian ipolucci he wrapped who's uh
brilliant joke writer check out her new
album uh baby skeleton she's
some of the best dude she might have my
favorite joke of like the last few years
where uh really she said my boyfriend
threatened to kill himself
and i was like great now i can't kill
myself or people are gonna think we were
in love
ah that is genius level
joke writing that's like [ __ ]
that you're cramming i love jokes that
crammed so much into one line
yes yes that's got that joke's got depth
um yeah check out her album she also did
a degenerates
on netflix a half hour thing or 20
minutes on netflix
and it's so dark i don't know if i'm
allowed to say this but they had to cut
one of her jokes so that's
so get the album so you can hear all of
it yeah i mean she really
is uh unapologetic i know people like
use terms like that
in comedy but like she earned it she's
earned a lot a lot of people like you
see the hacky [ __ ] with like the
caution tape over your
mouth and the headshot but like she's an
edgy comic
well like that's who she is like i've
spent time with her my friend
like she really is dark and
but she's a good person like i love
people like that who are like
their minds are dark their jokes are
dark but you hang out with them and
you're like you're you're a good human
being like
she rules yeah i tend to believe that a
lot of the people who say the crazy [ __ ]
on stage tend to be the nicest off stage
and flip that too look at cosby you know
you know you're getting it out on stage
in a comedic way
or in an in an outlet that's silly hey
we're on stage we're doing crazy [ __ ] up
here
it's almost healthier than doing it in
real life that's a good point it's
almost it's not just comedy it's almost
like anything where you're like i'm the
sweet guy
yeah yeah like i'm the sweet guy in the
show i'm this i'm the musician who's
absent you know
but then you're like then you're like oh
this dude's into like [ __ ] femdum
getting pegged and like [ __ ] you know
banging kids and [ __ ] and you're just
like yeah
oh cause he was hiding so much that he
just had this dark side
yes if you're like getting there was
this famous quote i think it's gustav
luber said be violent in your art so you
can be ordinary in your life
and that's kind of a cool that's kind of
a cool way to live i think where you're
like
all right i'm getting it out you know
what it means yes
uh yes i don't think wes craven is
killing people you know he nails it in
the art
although john carpenter went on a spree
in the 80s
but hey look at matt lauer the guy's uh
is sunshine and
lollipops at 7 a.m that's not healthy
yeah but then at the same time like you
know like i think like jimmy fallon is
that dude
i really do like i i think he is that i
think he's like
you know a nice i think he's that nice
upbeat guy
for real yeah he's definitely a nice guy
but he likes the sauce
and i think he's a drinker but he's how
you cut it but fallon is an old school
entertainer like
he is like i'm gonna sing and [ __ ] i'm
gonna dance and [ __ ]
and i'm gonna [ __ ] get lit up on
booze like
he's almost like a dean martin type of
dude right
well you're like so i mean yeah i think
that's cool too i mean
you know i go look i don't watch any
late night i'm not gonna i mean
who watches late night anymore really i
don't know i think fallon's wife
and that's about it but no i'm with you
it's it's it's
kind of a dying art and especially the
pandemic really was almost a nail in the
coffin for it
uh so yeah it's it's tough but you know
i i i respect it i mean
we did a million uh late night sets and
it's fun going to 30 rocks fun putting a
suit on
so fun because we talked about the suit
the suit is only appropriate for like
do you want you didn't wear a suit on
the conan but you wear a suit on like
fallon colbert
yeah do you wear it those are the only
two that's
it yeah yeah there's something about
that ed sullivan theater there's
something about the 30 rock it just
feels
old school feels [ __ ] feels a little
more high-end
where's the phone yeah they were they
would throw in
they'd appreciate it if you worse yes
yes
exactly and look i i i hum and haul and
i go oh
these [ __ ] suits but i enjoy it i'm
not gonna lie
yeah it looks good man it's cool it's
cool to have like one picture of us
we're in like a [ __ ] tailored p piece
of clothing
yes yeah it's rare but it's nice you
know what's the best
is you get a you get a shot of us at
joel's wedding or something
we're all getting hammered in suits that
is my favorite photo
we look we look cool in season like [ __ ]
we would have been like cool businessmen
yeah i know a couple of mad men doing ad
sales or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] mad men dude
that would be my dream if i didn't do
comedy just
because it's creative still you're still
exactly you're being creative but you
still get to get [ __ ] up it's close to
comedy
right it really is yeah and it involves
pleasing people and all that but it's
still a little too much responsibility
but
let me give you my uh my my big pet
peeve please
and this is an epidemic all over the
world so i'm gonna say this
and people listening are gonna go [ __ ] i
feel
seen or whatever the kids are saying but
people are saying the word like too much
it's a problem i was eating like buffalo
wings the other day and they were like
so hot no you were eating buffalo wings
you weren't eating like buffalo wings
drives me nuts sometimes people get
three three or four into
a sentence and it's so unnecessary and
it hurts language there's adjectives
that can really spice up a sentence and
you're saying
this is like another word it's like this
or it's like that just say what it's
like or what it is
ah i love it it's not just like or
whatever
it's like so okay cool story i gotta
send this to you my history teacher in
sixth grade was a slam poet and he was
[ __ ]
hilarious like one of the one of the
funniest people
his name's taylor molly uh ta
you know how you spell taylor and then
m-a-l-i
really talented dude he does slam poetry
but it's [ __ ]
like it's written like stand up it's
like carl and s type of like word play
yeah and he has a bit called like i
think the
one that's really popular is called or
like whatever
where he mocks people who go uh i miss
people having
confidence in what they're saying so
that's the whole thing he's mocking and
i
totally agree because uh what happened
to that like people used to
so he said his closing line to this
rant as he goes it's not enough to
question authority you need to speak
with it as well
he's very he's very interesting very
cool so he was a great teacher and he's
also
just an interesting guy but i remember
seeing that and being like he didn't we
didn't know he was just like
kind of like most deaf is bringing him
on stage and these whoa
[Music]
know this and he's like i love this guy
it's hilarious so wow
uh yeah he was a cool guy so
anyway yeah i'm with you man like
like uh it's just it's in the vernacular
now it's part of the culture and
and i you got whatever i would throw in
you know you know it was a big one no
you're watching something come on yeah
i'm guilty of it especially when i'm
hungover here's what i'll do
a lot is this is what i do i go [ __ ]
uh
yeah yeah is the alcoholic version of
you know
yeah you just gotta watch it around mom
you know oh see i just did it
but yeah you gotta watch it around the
the folks with the [ __ ]
but i talk to older people and it's kind
of refreshing because they're not going
uh
so i was eating these like uh like
cereal you were eating cereal there was
no like
i have a neighbor who will do one he
does this he always goes he sees me in
the hallway and he goes hey
have a good night huh
i think the huh is kind of weird it's
like huh like
why can't you just say have a good night
yeah yeah colin quinn's got that great
joke where they answered the question
for you it's like
oh it's a pretty good day right
i don't know yeah how's your day going
good that was it how's your day going
good
well let me say how it's going don't
answer it
yeah it it we've gotten lazy in language
i mean it's
that's what it is we're just very lazy
in how we speak
and people people speaking confidently
is
refreshing it's refreshing and people
speaking with
just uh the right amount of good words
and not
kind of prolonging it because they can't
think of good adjectives
it's so nice a long a storyteller who
can't wrap it up
someone who just takes just agreed what
if i did this for like five minutes
someone who's just
greedy someone who's greedy with their
language and like
whatever uh yeah yeah
someone who's greedy with their language
and
can't wrap it up like use your word
economy use your phone
also you think attention spans are
getting shorter and shorter so you'd
think we'd be quicker with the with the
[ __ ] getting it out but
it feels almost like we're taking longer
we are taking longer
yeah our attention spans have gotten
shorter but our stories have gotten
longer because we're getting dumber
hey now that was a good sentence
you got it all in tightly that was
perfect
attention spans are getting shorter
stories are getting longer
we're getting dumber boom there is
something about that where
when you're with someone who can tell a
story it feels so good
when you just you're like oh you i can
be around you
yeah yeah that that's one great thing
about hanging with comics is
you can tell they've told the story a
few times it's got the beats it's got
the ending it comes together
it's got a good grip [ __ ] in the
beginning nothing worse than the guy
who's got the story with no
punch i love a workshop story some
people are like
you [ __ ] oh you've you've clearly
told this to a bunch of people
like what are you working on i'm like
give me the work done story yes i want
the hits play the hits i don't want your
your your new stuff
on the story front yeah i don't want to
see i don't want to see [ __ ] journey
work out new material
yeah what play don't stop believing and
get off get off the shave all right
yeah i don't want to don't stop like
believing in things
whatever you know
come on i got i got i got another good i
don't know if i complained about this
pet peeve last week as well but
the idea is the people that bail on
plans but then text you
where are you i'm meeting you right now
did i give you that one last week no
what do you
what do you mean well people were like
all right let's uh
tomorrow night i'll come over yeah
sounds good come over tomorrow night and
then they're just like they don't come
but then they're like
two days they text you where are you i'm
meeting you right now and you're like
wait what oh yeah i don't like that that
makes me feel suffocated
like they think hey i blew off this one
but i'm making it up now
and you think hey you're making it up
for you i'm not ready you never checked
in on me
well that's the tough thing about us is
that like our dates
are on websites and [ __ ] so our friends
our friends like we can't blow them off
they could find us yeah yeah true
true ah that is tough but sometimes you
just not up for a zoom but
you can't really bail on a zoom tough to
balance a zoom also tough to be late on
a zoom
yeah not a fan of that if you're not
there on the dot you're kind of a dick
yeah at least send a text like hey i'm
running home i'll be there in two
minutes something
but yeah just the straight up late is is
tough on a zoo
oh this is one this is a good drinking
one people who don't accept
that you won't take a shot with them oh
that's a nightmare
i'm in my 30s here come on i got a
cocktail already you want me to have
liquor on top of liquor
it's like hey man whatever okay
yeah i'm [ __ ] right no but you know
people that don't expect
they don't accept it and you say hey i'm
already doing a drink
i'm a sipper i'm a [ __ ] adult adult
sip
children shoot okay you want to be a kid
or do you want to be an adult
choose a path and stick with it and this
assumption that i want that
i do i bought you a shot what the [ __ ]
yeah but you didn't even ask me what if
i just bought you a dress
you're gonna put that on there's no
you didn't even ask me what i wanted
i'll do the shot if you put the dress on
how about there we go
yeah you put on a blouse i'll shoot
southern comfort with you deal
[Applause]
yeah uh what do you got on
recommendation what do i have what i
uh the blind date was one i gotta say
man i re-watched
i watched i've never seen the movie the
odd couple i've read the play but i've
never seen the movie and our boy
salaccus
gave me a ton of [ __ ] for it so last
night i figured you know what let me
late night watch this
it's terrific it's walter matthau jack
lemmon
amazing writing i mean what i love about
it it's on amazon by the way
if you want to stream it okay but uh
what i love about it is like
it's two guys who are down on their luck
who just [ __ ] bond it starts in a
kind of a dark place for jack lemmon
who is going to kill himself so he
checks into a hotel to kill himself but
his wife leaves him
he tries to open the window and he pulls
his back out so he doesn't do it
so already like you've combined dark and
comic so i love that
love it he shows up after taking pills
to the card game that walter matthau and
he lives in like an eight bedroom on
central park west
which is [ __ ] amazing we were like
he's like i don't want to be alone
you're like you [ __ ] [ __ ] i love
this playing his car
he lives in an eight bedroom but he's
making all his friends like [ __ ]
ham sandwiches and like ah cigars
a refrigerator that doesn't work right
right he's drinking warm beer so
jack lemmon comes by and they're like
he's gonna he's
he's gonna kill himself we're scared
he's gonna kill himself he tells him he
takes a whole bottle of pills they call
an ambulance he goes whoa don't call an
ambulance he could have take he didn't
say what kind of pills it could have
been vitamins he could be the healthiest
one of all of us
great one-liners like that it's a great
movie i loved it
i mean it's a classic so much it's a
neil simon right
yeah yeah so it's this huge play then a
movie and then it was a show for like
eight years
so yeah yeah and i think they've remade
it since then
i mean every show is the odd couple and
that's what every show is it's a
prototype for all these other shows so
that's when you know something's a real
staple when they just keep remaking it
yeah i mean so many i mean peep show is
one of my all-time favorite shows too
it's on amazon and that's it's basically
the odd couple it's like a nerdy
history buff who works in accounting and
the guy who wishes he was a musician
you know if you haven't seen that if you
haven't seen that show [ __ ]
watch it it's it's people keep
recommending that to me and i gotta
watch it
it might be it it's probably top five
comedies for me
for for for tv shows i would say yeah
wow okay
i'm such a xenophobe i'm like ah accents
blow me
dude it's you might not laugh harder at
a show ever it's like wow
it takes a minute but it's like nine
seasons but there's six episodes per
season and they're all
killer all right all right i'll check it
out by the way speaking of odd couples
it's
another 48 hours rush hour those are all
basically just odd couples the the
straight edge
mises the meets the wild card black guy
asian guy
whatever trading places yes odd couple
beverly hills cobb kind of midnight run
yes
just odd couple in a police setting
that's all it is
two two dudes who just don't get along
yeah you're right it's it's
the prototype there you go all right
good wreck i
i saw that when i was younger but i
gotta re-watch it i just love the show
so i'm on a good call yeah and plus
those
uh simon lemon matthau you can't go
wrong
they're so good another if you haven't
seen another great lemon movie is
everyone i'm sure have seen this but the
apartment is like apartment yeah
[ __ ] fred mcmurray jack lemmon
perfect brilliant movie
great movie um all right here's my
record this is a weird one i don't know
if you caught it yet but i'm gonna say
the first half of the patrice dock
wow is lights out it's about an hour
long but the first half
i i was tearing up it's so good
when you watch it i well you know me i
got my
uh shady little deal there with the
television set
i'm not gonna get into it because i got
in trouble but
uh i watch it on that and
it is it they have so much footage of
him starting out he's this fat
big guy in boston and he's a nobody and
he's got notes on stage
and his ideas are brilliant even though
it's new when he's working it out and
he's he's
green you're like oh you got the best
you got a great head for comedy you got
a great mind
and just seeing him move to new york and
he's humble in the beginning he's not a
[ __ ]
dick like he is you know a regular time
and uh
there's one point where keith robinson
goes
i showed patrice boston comedy club and
it was a tell
it was chappelle it was louie it was all
these killers kevin brennan
and he goes i can't go on i'm not ready
yet and he had to leave and go
try to get better and then come back wow
so just
all that cool stuff and it made you see
comedy for how we used to see it because
now comedy's gotten so
oversaturated and these horrific netflix
specials and who's got heat
and who's the it guy or the it gal and
it was just funny
for funny sake who had the best bit who
had the good observation who had the
best takes
and it brought me back and it was
beautiful that is
so cool i gotta watch it i'll watch it
tonight i mean the idea of striving for
greatness is what patrice was doing i
mean if you haven't seen elephant in the
room is
comedy central i think it's one of the
best hour specials of all time i mean
it's amazing
he was so good he does the thing that i
love where he would like
bait you with a provocative set up
and still surprise you i mean he yes i
mean
the the kidnapped white girl bit i mean
like every bit
the bit about the dogs you know i mean
like yeah he really just
[ __ ] ruled and i won't even try to
retell his bits because no one tells him
like him
right right uh but yeah i gotta watch it
but so much has changed we're like now
i'll be writing a joke about a black guy
and i'll just make him a jew
and the joke because i'm like i don't
want to deal with the the groans or the
so i end up trashing jews at half my act
cause i'm like well this was about a
puerto rican or
or an indian and everybody's fine with
you
and you just know i'll come to your
[ __ ] rescue if [ __ ] goes bad is that
what it is
i just know because i guess you guys are
doing so well that people are ah they
can take a joke they're they're strong
no i don't think so i mean like there
was a whole thing about you know che got
[ __ ]
oh that's true so i started looking into
it and of course it's [ __ ] ludicrous
of course it's like yeah an inoffensive
joke that our buddy
che told who's uh so [ __ ]
like it was so innocuous
and so just silly and like che is such a
[ __ ] sweetheart it's so weird that
people
uh and he's also a [ __ ] brilliant
comic i mean he really
is he's one of the he's one of the
funniest people
you know i know i think it's a great
sign that
a week ago the right hated them or the
left hated them and then a week later
the rite hates them
that's what you should be doing as a
comic you should just be pushing buttons
all over the place
not biased it's a good point i mean like
bill maher is constantly in [ __ ]
and i like a lot of what he says man
i mean i'll say this about bill maher
too love him or hate him
there is not a human being who has more
a more diverse uh group of guests in
terms of
i don't think anyone i don't think
anyone on tv
like msnbc has their mission where
they're like everything's going to be
this
fox news has their mission where
everything's going to be this and bill
maher's like
yeah he he leans liberal for sure but he
pisses off liberal more than anybody
living with anybody
i know and he has cons i mean he had i
think people were pissing megan kelly on
i was like i listened to their talk i
thought it was pretty reasonable so
uh i agree i i think a lot of
outrage outrage is like currency now
outrageous yeah
you know and i i think bill maher
i think his show is great i really do i
i it's
it's not only great and i must sound
like a pretentious company it's
important
because yeah if we don't have you know
they give give them shiver having megan
kelly on but
don't you want to hear if she's the
enemy why would you want to get the ammo
let's hear what the enemy has to say or
whatever it is it's so stupid
it's so stupid we're closed-minded
where yeah i think yeah i think
more shows need to kind of have
less of an agenda yes and more of a show
because yeah i think you learn more
about not just that but about yourself
or you're like oh this is actually like
a more
i hate using the word safe but like if
you have a conservative on msnbc they're
only having that person on
to like sell the talking points that
they want to sell those are like
pre-approved questions right
same goes for fox news if you have like
the fox news liberal so it's like
yep when this is hbo which obviously is
a [ __ ]
liberal you know network i mean
look what they're making but i mean bill
moore kind of has the guests that he
wants so it's kind of
it's it's kind of cool i think it's kind
of cool that that show exists
and uh i completely agree i see people
trying to drag him on social media and i
i think it's
you know it's unfair and it's wrong i
mean let the guy do his thing and you're
still
watching i i hate these people like oh
can you believe you had this guest
i got to see what he's got to say well
then you can't [ __ ] on it if you're
going to watch it
i also think it's kind of interesting
like he had milo yiannopoulos on when
milo had all that heat
and like guess what man sometimes you
have those guests on and they fizzle out
and that dude like he fizzled out
you know like people people are like
to give this person a platform i think
well i think sometimes exposing people
is not having
to back up you know their ideology
if you have them on it kind of it's kind
of good i think it's kind of nice to
yeah bang themselves i'm a little buzzed
right now so i'm not as articulate as i
was an hour ago but uh
no i completely agree it's almost like
when you get heckled
and you you kind of just pause and let
the guy
bury his own dig his own grave and you
barely have to do anything it's the same
thing i'm not i'm not welcoming hecklers
i'm not approving of it i'm just letting
the guy hang himself with his own rope
that's a good point it's isn't it great
when you just have to repeat what they
say
and then you just [ __ ] that one hit
and you're like i'm out yeah
nothing better than when they say a line
back to you and it gets nothing and you
go
it's not that easy is it yeah you're not
that
not that funny i've been killing for 45
minutes you you can't get one line out
you [ __ ] coos
this is a good one what uh give me uh do
you have any bits you're working on
oh yeah i gotta i got a couple um
yeah i had a fun productive weekend
uh let me see here we go
this one this one's all over the road
but maybe you can
maybe you can put it together i get the
same one so
okay we'll help each other uh
so everybody always says uh oh
man they don't like an opinionated woman
men hate an opinionated woman
i'm like i completely disagree there's
nothing worse than a woman with no
opinion
where should we eat i don't know what
kind of food do you like
i don't care whatever you like and
you're like give me an opinion
you know like and then the joke is uh
even if a woman's like uh hey
is it just me or do chinese people smell
different i'm like you're a keeper
that it's such a crazy opinion i'm like
this is interesting at least we can
bounce ideas off of each other i want an
opinion there's nothing worse to me than
no opinion
maybe the angle is that like an
opinion's good when the opinion goes too
maybe i think it's funnier if like she's
got good opinions at first and that's
the third and where you're like you're
like all right never mind
like you want you want opinions to a
degree
aha yeah they still have to be good
opinions
sucks you're like wait what exactly like
opinion's
good but you want the opinions to line
up at some point where you're like
she's like [ __ ] like feminist that's
opinionated i love i love an opinion but
then when it's
what if it turns into like feminists we
were like all right i think women
deserve equal rights
of course i think you better [ __ ]
trash like all right calm down a second
right and then they go you don't like an
opinion of a woman no i just don't like
that opinion
yeah maybe there's nothing here no no
hold on there is something here
okay an opinionated woman
i like an opinionated woman to a point
to a point it depends on the opinion i
guess
yeah i say hey if your opinions are if
your opinions aren't awful
you think i want to go out with a boar
i'd rather in a bit but then maybe
you're like maybe the angle of the turn
is
i'll take even like horrible opinions
though yes over
over no opinions because at least at
least horrible opinions
i'm engaged yes that's kind of what i
was trying to get out with the chinese
smelly
so maybe yeah so maybe if maybe before
you go she says nothing you're just like
all right i i don't know what to say and
then she does that and you go
you're a [ __ ] idiot you're like well
at least i can at least i'm getting a
reaction with this
yeah yeah exactly at least you have some
thoughts here
yeah when you go out with someone and
they keep saying dumb [ __ ] where you're
like yeah well at least you're moving
things forward
right right here's why i like here's why
i like
strong opinions i know i can get out
sooner if you're giving me no opinions
i'm dating this girl for three months
until she finally says something stupid
i'm like
[ __ ] i could have left three months ago
if you'd only opened your mouth
interesting yeah i get to know you more
even if it's horrible at least i know
what i'm dealing with
yes that's good that's good all right
all
right
i think strong opinions on a first date
are great great
because i know who you are right right
even if it's bad i still want to know
it's almost like when like my friend of
mine he's a black guy he's like
everybody hates rebel flags i like when
a guy's got a rebel flags at least i
know he's racist
right i'd rather know roy wood right is
that roy wood
yeah yeah there you go what would it
have been about like now
we can't tell that's a [ __ ] great
where it would be so anyway
he's a beast but anyway uh
yeah i mean that's to me that's kind of
like everyone's on their best behavior
on the first date and it
almost sets us back it's like [ __ ] i i
bought four more dinners
before finding out you're [ __ ] you
know a lunatic
yeah it's terrible yeah yeah eight
hundred dollars you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] yeah you tricked me i i'm
six months in i just found out you found
you think the moon landing's fake
[Laughter]
yeah you should have told me that the
first night i would have i would have
fell in love with you
all right all right that's something
okay thank you
that helps because that tightens it up a
little bit mine was a little
loosey-goosey
no there's something there for sure i
had this angle about uh so this is like
a mass shooting years ago in georgia
that didn't happen
because this kid came in with 500 rounds
an ak-47 whatever and uh
he shows up whatever i said it again he
shows up
and the teacher stops him and she goes
what are you doing and the line i said
was you know she probably knew but she
was an ice breaker you know
and he said no one loves me so she said
i love you
you know and uh i love you
yeah and this [ __ ] idiot kid believed
her thank god
and he gets arrested and didn't kill
anybody so
my angle was like she stopped the mass
shooting but some women issues were
definitely born on that day
i mean like like he's sitting in a jail
cell like she [ __ ] lied to me i
thought she loved me
you know yes yes so i don't know where
to go
quite yet one of my angles one of my
thoughts was uh
like it's gonna be much tougher to pull
that at the at the reunion
you know the the high school reunion
he goes back and she and she's like what
are you doing and he's like no one loves
me and she's like and he goes no
no i'm not falling for that [ __ ] again
don't try to pull that
and she's like this time and he's like
i've been burned before and she's like
all right i don't know quite where to go
with it but like
i love you as like a grenade you only
get one and so
if he comes back yeah she's she's
screwed luckily he's in jail for life
but it also
it kind of proves that lying can save
your ass i mean maybe if there's a woman
out there whose husband is abusive
and he's like you think i got a small
dick she's like no you got a huge dick
and he's like all right i won't hit you
i don't know something we're lying can
save the day we're taught not to lie
all day long but it can save you i think
lying when the other person's holding
the gun is acceptable
yeah there you go if they're holding a
gun you could
you could whatever it takes to get out
of that gun situation
yes yeah also like man a lot of kids
who are doing that [ __ ] like women
young women tell a guy you love him
because they're the ones [ __ ]
shooting that [ __ ] up
tell a guy you love him if a guy is
pissed about [ __ ] heartbreak
he's not gonna shoot up the whole school
this is because no one loves him he
shouldn't have everyone
i don't know where to go with this but
there's something here for sure right i
mean there's definitely something here
and uh
i mean we've all done it with our
girlfriend she's like do i look fat in
this
and you're like if you tell the truth
you'll get stabbed
so i'm protecting my ass
you gotta lie sometimes i think that's
just the the nature of life
i think yeah women say they want honesty
at all times try being honest about
everything and you will get killed you
gotta [ __ ]
you have to [ __ ] soften it pour some
[ __ ] water in it
dilute it a little bit like i mean how
many times has a woman got like
i've seen my boyfriend my boyfriend i've
seen my friend and he's got a girlfriend
and he's like
she's like do i look good in this honey
and he's like you always look good babe
and she goes that's a good guy he knows
just what to say
like he clearly lied and you're happy
about it
i think it's almost a man with a gun is
the same
reasoning as a lady all the time
you know it's life or death all the time
with a guy with a gun and a woman
looking a woman looking for a compliment
it's the same
it's the same situation that's
interesting
you have to always just go with the lie
whether
it's a lady or a guy with a gun a guy
with a gun and a woman or a safe yeah
either way you're [ __ ] finished
yeah either way you're finished either
way you're dead
all right well that's funny this has
been a [ __ ] hot up again
i'm loving these dude we're killing
these i hope we're doing well i feel
like you know i might be not in my
most coherent sense same way i'm saying
that lockable goes right to the
noggin but this is fun man oh oh we
forgot through the ad
oh [ __ ] yeah all right let's do an ad
real quick uh
i mean i can't i'm i'm pumped for this
ad right here
we might be drunk it's brought to you by
blue chew get more confidence in the
bedroom
blue chew offers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis
but it's chewable yeah if you don't like
swallowing pills this is for you it
works fast take it day or night
and you'll save a ton of money compared
to the name brands blue chew
is the best thing on the internet i know
you've heard of this guys
an online prescription service that
means no doctor's office no wait in line
take a licensed medical provider to get
your prescriptions
all online everything bluetooth
prescribed ships right to your door in a
discrete package
right special offer just for you drunks
visit bluetooth.com and get your first
shipment for free
when you use the promo code drink that's
not drunk that's
drink all right just five dollars
shipping again that's
bluechew.com promo code drink
for free tonight yeah let me just let me
just riff on blue chew i i i got a
package
in the mail it was five bucks they sent
it right to your house the discreet
packaging was so good
i tried it out it works like a charm i
can't i
i loved it i i'm almost nervous about it
because it works so well that you just
don't want to rely on it but
i mean hey if you if you think you need
it get it because it is good stuff
it works and uh you'll never let anyone
down again
man or woman so yeah it works so don't
take it in a
you know a funeral or something because
uh you'll be screwed but it
it's good stuff i can vouch if you want
to [ __ ] bring the heat if you want to
impress a woman
yes here here all right good stuff
i will see you next week baby i can't
wait to see what you're you're sipping
on then
can't wait and listen to our patreon at
uh yeah
patreon.com we might be drunk pod
email us at uh we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com
with your pet peeves if you wanna hit us
with a joke uh
a drink if you just want to hit us with
anything we'll talk about it and
uh and give us five stars on itunes
yeah we're on itunes spotify you name it
so uh tell a friend spread the word and
uh
keep drinking unless you're sober